au coeur de paris à deux pas du louvre
et à côté du palais royal existe le plus
ancien lieu de culture populaire de
france depuis 1680 la comédie française
offre au public le meilleur du théâtre
bienvenus nous vous ouvrons les portes
de la ruche créé sept ans après la mort
de molière
la comédie française offre dans un lieu
exceptionnel de nombreux spectacles
mais avant de se dévoiler au public dans
la prestigieuse salle richelieu
les pièces sont un travail de longue
haleine les textes sont choisis par un
comité composé de l'administrateur du
doyen et de comédien sociétaire
c'est ici que se passent les comités de
l'extérieur aussi
puis vient le choix et la construction
des décors dans des ateliers unique en
europe bois fer peinture tous les corps
de métiers sont au service du spectacle
évidemment le décor c'est central
puisque c'est là que tout va se passer
donc en fait l' influence sur le jeu
elle est extrêmement grande le choix des
costumes est également primordial ici on
dessine regroupe beaucoup
chaque robe chaque geste chaque chapeau
chaque pièce est unique est fait sur
mesure
ce sont plus de 50 me costumes qui ont
été fabriqués par les petites mains de
la comédie française
mais passons dans le secret des
répétitions
tout d'abord une lecture avec m de
rancennes et l'ensemble des comédiens
pour décortiquer les subtilités du texte
si tu mets la panique c'est évident
d'être que dans du raisonnement froid
ensuite de nombreuses répétitions avec
décors et costumes dont les conditions
réelles du spectacle tant pis tant pis
si c'est pas bien mais parce que toute
façon ça va se lever à l'intérêt oui
on enchaîne
alors que le public attend avant de
pénétrer dans la salle richelieu
les comédiens et techniciens se
concentrent et règle les derniers
détails avant le lever du rideau
voilà tout est prêt il ne vous reste
qu'à découvrir le spectacle qui va
commencer
[Musique]
bienvenue à la comédie française